hello folks welcome to rational science
i'm going to tell you a little bit what
happened the other day i was
sick suddenly i had a bad feeling in my
chest i thought i had some uh heart
problem
and uh this is like the third time that
i get this in two years
several months apart
and so i don't think it's related to
copic or anything like that
uh
a little later i felt a little better
but two hours after that i got it again
went to sleep woke up in the morning
i
felt okay when i woke up but a little
later i had the same problem so i
decided to see the doctor went to see
the doctor they took my pressure checked
my heart
pressure was a little high
and so they said well just in case i'm
going to send you to
the hospital so i went to the hospital
and they had me
under observation for about five hours
and checking my heart my pressure the
blood that sort of thing served for my
yearly checkup while i was there
and um
yeah i had a little bit of higher
pressure i don't know why i usually have
normal pressure
and my blood came out with higher
glucose which means uh you know my one
of my brothers died this year he died of
diabetes
and i'm a little worried about that so
um
i probably have to change my diet a
little bit and do a little more exercise
so maybe that's what it's about but i
think it was a muscle spasm that was
maybe pressing my lungs
and uh maybe that's why it was affecting
my breathing
anyways uh what you learn after being
five hours in a bed at the hospital is
that
all you need
uh the only prerequisite to
die is to be alive
it's a black or white issue okay so
either you're a library you're dead
black or white no in between some people
believe that there's this no man's land
you're not neither in heaven or in hell
i don't think so you're either dead or
you're alive some people even believe
you come back from the dead you know
that uh
you know the spirit comes back
you know we have all these theories out
there
anyways i had uh the other day asked the
question a couple questions okay
will ma man live another thousand years
will we live the next hundred years in
either service economy or in a leisure
unemployment
economy of some kind
and the third one will we ever have a
world government
only one person apparently answered
the questions he said
no yes yes no in other words will man
live another thousand years now
and will we ever have a world government
no
but he believes probably a young fellow
that
we will live
another 100 years
and it's going to be one of those two
service economy
and or right leisure unemployment
economy
and um yeah i have uh a difference of
opinion with them i don't think uh
that's going to happen and i think one
of the reasons a lot of these uh
people today believe
that there's going to be
still more uh time ahead of us a hundred
years is they say well you know i want
to live my life i want to get my social
security i want to retire and then when
i die i don't care what happens
that's the notion they have in in the
back of their minds
and all i want to do is clarify for you
that um
you know we would all love to live
forever you know uh maybe
uh but there's a problem there's a
problem and the problem is that
when extinction comes around okay when
whenever it comes around it doesn't
matter you know if this is the last
generation or not but whenever it comes
around
in the last generation you'll find
people who are old and people who are
young you'll find toddlers dying
together with grandpa fathers you know
and so um
you know uh this notion that
uh
you know
you're gonna live
your life and then it's gonna happen
after you
leave and you don't care
uh it'd be nice but maybe you're one of
those 20 or 30 or 40 years old who's
gonna die together with the 80 years old
and with the two-year-old toddlers
okay so
this is what i think is going to happen
i can give you is my opinion on that
as far as extinction is concerned i'm
looking at one thing and one thing only
and that's the mechanism okay that's
what concerns science not the date
when it's gonna happen okay
so uh we all have different opinions on
the date
okay
and i don't venture dates i i do venture
dates but
you know i take that with a grain of
salt and i ask you to do that as well
uh the important thing is
the mechanism what is going to cause the
extinction of man
because that relates to science why
because we're trying to explain how
extinctions happened in the past how did
the dinosaurs die how did the traffic uh
archosaurs die
that's what we want to understand okay
we understand them understand the
mechanism okay uh last time i mentioned
uh about argentina i was there a little
while ago and there was another
uh
article
as saying essentially that uh
everybody's essentially gonna follow
argentina you know and at the
economy there is a shambles by the way
you know
great inflation
which is happening elsewhere as well in
fact it's happening in the united states
it's happening here in germany okay
and says an analyst that currency broker
rwanda said a new
uh deal would likely involve latin
america's third largest economy having
to take some tough medicine what's the
medicine well at the bottom you see it
there says um
will require major cuts with public
spending
and you know people over there have
gotten used to public spending you know
money comes in easy from the government
and people kind of liked that or got
they gotten used to it
and i'm not sure uh
any politician in argentina will be able
to go in there and suddenly say well you
know we're gonna have to reduce your
income
here we have inflation on the one hand
you know people can't even make it to
the end of the month and on top of that
the government's going to somehow cut
that
in order to pay
the international monetary fund or the
world bank or whoever
i don't think so
i think they're gonna in the end decide
to screw the people
they're gonna do the best they can you
know try to walk a fine line between the
imf and the
uh so and uh i think a lot of economies
in the world will be following the uh
course that argentina has uh been
following lately which is you know
they're gonna default on their debt they
can't pay they don't have enough money
and
you know if they do pay it then they
have to squeeze the people and they
won't get voted to office so there's
this whole run around one thing leads to
another i don't think there's a solution
i think it's part of the process
of the extinction of men
uh the global economy collapsing and no
one being able to do anything about it
okay
so yeah all this stuff about
um that the rich and powerful well in
fact i'll be talking about that next so
here it is uh a little while fella says
you should read a uh an interesting
article sends me to this article talking
about claus klaus schwab we talked a
little bit about him lately uh school
for covid dictators plan for great reset
he talks about the great reason talks
about the fourth industrial revolution
uh the singularity all that nonsense
right
and says their economist ernst wolfe
believes that a hidden alliance of
political and corporate leaders is
exploiting the uh pandemic with um
uh
i'm of cour with the aim of crushing
uh crashing national economies and
introducing a global digital currency
okay so um
uh yeah um
we have this these conspiracy theories
about the rich and powerful
uh the filthy rich and wealthy i guess
that uh are taking over the world and
they're deciding what to do you know but
you know the first thing you should
come to grips with is that this has
happened always there's always been rich
people in every single age
uh was there a conspiracy well you can
call it a conspiracy
in the sense that yeah there's always
been rich people who took decisions for
the majority of population
you know we i talked about that the
other day the philosopher kings they
rule
and uh they have the money to rule so uh
do you have any money to rule
if you don't well then you got a problem
right so these people uh ruled with
power and the power comes from the money
that they own the assets etc and they
all get together and they all more or
less take decisions for the rest of
humanity
so that's normal now are they taking
advantage of this coping uh yeah and uh
there is a little bit of problem there
because
you know
i believe there is a bug out there first
of all okay i think there is
i'm not sure about it but
if i had to
weigh it i'd say 60 70 chance that there
is
a bug out there okay
uh
should we stop the global economy
because of that should we take all these
draconian measures
and uh you know kill the tourist
industry uh prevent people from
traveling prevent people from going to
the hotels and restaurants etc
i don't know i think it's uh probably
overkill
but on the other hand if you don't do
that well maybe you're gonna fill the
hospitals and the morgues and there's
not enough personnel to take care of
all this population that suddenly gets
sick
so what do you do you're caught like
between the sword and the wall you know
so i don't know what the solution is all
i'm saying is there probably is a bug
out there what and some people are
taking advantage of that no doubt about
that and the question is can we do
anything about it
and should we do anything about it or
should we let
assuming there's a bug right should we
let people die just you know whoever
gets it and died will you die you ever
get sick and recovers fine you recovered
whoever wants to get the shot gets the
shot whoever doesn't doesn't
but to put all these draconian measures
i don't know i don't know if that's uh
the way to treat this because you may be
killing more people by killing the
economy or doing it faster for the world
okay in other words you may be um
inducing the extinction of man sooner
okay and so the question is
uh do we want to live longer and let
whoever dies die
or should we save everybody we can and
kill the economy and just bring about
the extinction of man sooner
i think that's the choice here okay okay
so uh the article said there the main
goal of the wef activities is to
facilitate further high-level
cooperation between big business and
national governments to destroy the
businesses of small and medium-sized
entrepreneurs so that multinational uh
corporations based in the united states
and china can monopolize business
everywhere okay
uh
it's like this guy discovered for the
first time in his life
that
the rich govern the world
now that's always happened again the
ultimate conclusion is that democracy as
we know it has been silently cancelled
uh i agree with what the other fellow
said the other day uh that i mentioned
there that there is no such thing as
democracy and there's never been
democracy it's always been the rule of
the rich the philosopher kings
or
the uh
philosopher rich
they rule the world they have the money
to rule the world they have the power
that's it and it's always been like that
so there's this democracy thing is
something new to me i never heard of it
what is that uh an examination of how
governance around the world works today
shows that an elite of super wealthy and
powerful individuals effectively control
everything that goes on in politics
yeah you just found out about that
i mean it's like is this new to you
the best way to combat these uh
designs is simply to educate people
about what is happening okay let's
educate them and for them to realize
that the narratives of the super
dangerous virus is a lie
again uh maybe that's an erroneous
conclusion that it's a lie uh
again the only reason i think it's uh
probably an erroneous conclusion is that
i don't think that enemy countries would
cooperate on that issue i don't think
iran
tuba would be in cahoots with the united
states and say oh
let's do the same thing to it let's tell
the same lie the same fib to our
population i don't think yuba would have
a
reason for that
unless there is really a bug out there
first of all second you know they're
losing tourism which is a big portion
has become a big portion of the cuban
economy
so for the cuba to cooperate with the
rich and powerful of the world because
there's a few rich and powerful people
ruling cuba you know
uh i don't think so i think that
i have to believe that there is a bug if
it's so universal
uh are people taking advantage of that
absolutely no doubt about that and uh
uh is there a conspiracy in the sense
that they created the bug in advance
to create a given situation
um i have doubts on that one it it is
possible that they have no solution to
the global economy and that they could
have done this to justify why they can't
fix the global economy that's one form
of reasoning you know one way you can
reason this thing out but again i don't
think enemy countries would cooperate
and
reach an agreement with these folks and
say let's all
tell the same lie to our people
that i have problems with
uh should we intervene
do something about it well again you
know maybe it's better to let people die
whoever whoever falls falls i'm sorry
you know even if it's someone in your
family or you you know
but uh i think that's the way that
should be handled uh because otherwise
we're killing the economy and that might
be
the the
remedy might be worse than the disease
okay
okay uh fellas just doubles up on that i
think bill needs to look at the covid it
is all about control aspect of
uh a bit harder yeah again a lot of
people think this is
a uh conspiracy and they don't want to
get the shots and they
uh
don't like the fact that the government
is forcing them to get the shots and
saying we're going to pass a law that
says that if you work
in such and such place you need the
vaccine if you go to a restaurant you
need a vaccine here they started
implementing that anyone who gets on a
public transportation now we'll have to
carry either
a the little passport the visa the covet
visa you need to show that you know that
you've been vaccinated or uh show that
you had a pcr test that morning okay
otherwise they i guess they find you
they arrest you they they execute i
don't know what they do
but uh yeah they're penalizing anyone
who doesn't get the shots and
again the only reason i got the shot is
i had to travel and boy even like that
it's a pain in the butt but if you don't
have the shots my god
they're gonna make life so miserable for
you you'd be you you you'd be uh
so sorry you didn't okay you'd say i'll
take the shot any day after the pain
they drive they make you go through okay
uh
phil says all forms of big government
including communism involved one group
of people invoking their will on others
absolutely it's always been like that
never changed okay
a
direct democracy and an informed
electorate could prevent cronyism
oh i don't know about that there's uh no
sing as a direct democracy but that's
what he suggests he says small
government
uh minimizes this by uh by only making
the most essential services okay for
example uh he says the essential i mean
necessary to prevent harm to others and
says everyone needs food drink and
shelter right but we can choose these
services ourselves without potentially
harming others so there's no need for an
authority to provide them for us
so you know again all these folks uh
these are the narco caps
uh the bottom line is they want
government off their backs they want uh
this
you could call it a world government or
the absence of a world government again
it's what marx had in mind these are
these they call themselves uh a narco
capitalist but they are a narco
communist they just don't know it okay
they haven't read marx uh mark's already
predicted
that was his prediction
it didn't come true and it won't come
true but he predicted this is what he
suggested he says there's going to be a
world government eventually he said and
then government itself will cease to
exist
there won't be any government uh how he
envisioned it in the 19th century i have
no idea but these people are
suggesting a way and the way they plan
to do it is this way here this is the
notion they have i'll illustrate it okay
everybody at home you know at their
office and they're going to vote with
computers okay so they're just going to
go in there and say well we're not going
to vote for people we're not going to
vote for politicians what we're going to
do is vote for specific issues
and i guess majority vote in that sense
it's going to be a democracy that these
people envision
you know i used to believe in a lot of
this stuff myself i have i'm guilty
right okay but no longer no way i think
first of all the extinction of man's
gonna occur uh much sooner
than we ever get this world government
which i don't think today even even if
given enough time i don't think it would
happen anyways okay but uh
extinction is gonna beat
any arrangement of that nature and any
uh arrangement that the what i call the
narco caps all these anarcho-capitalists
their dream is it's just the idealism is
nothing more than that it's never going
to happen there won't be a world
government and there won't be a
non-government in other words everybody
just voting from their homes and living
with their computers and just walking
around
uh be great if
uh it's an ideal world that exists in
the land of the klingons perhaps but not
here on earth never never will happen
okay
that's my five cents worth on that one
okay fella says
biggest brains is always better given
equal environment you leave out
environment i talked about brain the
other day brain size and so on whether
you know the
orientals have a little bigger brains
than the whites in the west and
which have bigger brains than the blacks
you know from africa uh people right and
i'm suggesting that brain size is not
necessarily a sign of intelligence
that's the first issue but this vowel
says uh it's environment that influences
uh brain size
all i can tell you is that that could be
uh the case historically in other words
through evolution that maybe in one side
of the world uh the brains grew a little
bigger because of some environmental
issue
but uh today i think that's over we're
not evolving uh that much today i think
uh
there could be some changes minor
changes but
you know the intelligence today has very
little to do with brain size that's
that's my argument okay now if
environment effects or food that you eat
affects your brain in some way well for
sure if you drug yourself with uh heroin
or cocaine i'm sure that affects your
brain so
does
once the effect goes away
do you recover your brains or have you
killed the cells in there
i don't know i don't know enough about
to have an opinion on that one
okay uh along the same lines paul says
the world's smartest man is a guy named
christopher langman okay thank god by
smartest i mean his iq is like 200 okay
so uh he goes on and says a few things
that this fellow came up with some
theories
and he says that this cognitive
theoretic model of the universe he can
with it he can prove the existence of
god
the soul and an afterlife using
mathematics
now isn't that intelligent how smart how
smart can you get you know
and uh yeah i don't know um again it
tells you something does an iq test
tell you anything about intelligence
call it an intelligence quotient test it
doesn't tell you anything about
intelligence and before you can answer
the question you absolutely need to
define the word intelligence otherwise
we don't know what you're talking about
right so i did define intelligence i
have it in
in my you stupid relativist.com site
uh you can look it up over there uh
because it's uh you know i've written
about that
and the bottom line is the following
that um
you know in the intelligence quotients
these iq tests
they test your memory
they don't test intelligence okay
and i'm sure
a lot of these mathematicians if the uh
iq tests were about mathematics they
would beat a lot of humanity you know i
mean if you just circumscribe it to
mathematics two equations right
i think they would beat a lot of
humanity you know a lot of people out
there don't even know how to add and so
uh
you would say okay this guy has an iq of
300 and this one only has one of five
you know he doesn't know how to add
well does that mean they're they're
intelligent
in what way are they intelligent are we
saying that they just memorize how to
do equations and now they just fill in
those equations with numbers and are
able to do calculations
is that a sign of intelligence
or is it a sign of memory
is memory intelligence okay
so you know if you can recite the bible
or or recite history anything like that
are you intelligent
uh
maybe have a lot of ram and very little
cpu
i mean you know think about it uh does
that tell any does the iq test tell you
anything about intelligence and again
you should have to define intelligence
uh the only thing i
quickly will mention when i wrote about
that is that everything
the cell the first cell which is the
first living entity
uh already had intelligence
life uh in that sense if it's
compartmentalized
is already a distribution of you know
segments of system it's a system
of uh compartments
that's already intelligence
every living entity has
intelligence okay
but for that you need to define
intelligence again
okay um
here's uh one thing i want to mention
and that's that you probably heard of uh
odysseus and he was uh about a thousand
years bc he went to the trojan war or so
the iliad tells us right
and then odysseus he came back
uh after 10 years he came back to his
town his island of ithaca
and along the way he had all these
adventures and that's the second part of
the you have the iliad which is
essentially the first part of homer's
book and the second part is the um
uh
what is it the
uh
uh uh the odc or whatever it's called i
can't remember love the name but anyways
it's uh the trip of odysseus back to his
home and he's got all these adventures
and one of those adventures is that he
uh ends up in the land of the lotus
eaters it looks something like this okay
and what happened was sailors you know
they got uh onshore and they started
eating this lotus stuff
and think of that as maybe heroin or
cocaine you know they were all high on
this stuff
and because of that they didn't want to
work
and they don't want to do anything they
just want to lay down and just eat the
lotus flower or leaves or whatever
and so
this is how they ended up and so
you know odysseus couldn't get him back
on the ship he just loved them there and
and left you know he went back home
without him
and uh today we have a similar situation
we don't call it the land of the lotus
eaters we call them the land of leisure
okay that's where we're at today you
know these people with their phones you
know
and they live glued to their phones you
know you you go on any public
transportation or out on the streets and
what do you see you see thousands of
people with their phones and they're
just staring at it reading it typing on
it
uh this is the land of the lotus eaters
of of our modern world it's uh i call it
the land of leisure why because most of
the
stuff that these people look at are
entertainment you know they uh they
write to peoples a lot of people work
with us as well you know they have to
communicate with their co-workers and so
on but what is it it's a world in which
um
we're just developing apps you know
applications
and they're selling this stuff and
people are including them in their uh
little devices
and it's all to create commercials so
that you buy more stuff and it's just a
cycle you know a
uh
cycle you know uh what they do is they
just look and it's like they're
hypnotized like they're lotus
they're like eating their lotus there by
looking at these things so yeah we're
already in the land of leisure
uh leisure is a big portion of our time
and of our work
and the question is whether we can live
amnesia alone can man live on leisure
alone which is maybe you can add it to
that those three questions i asked at
the beginning you know just add them to
it is leisure
uh
econo the leisure economy does that have
any future whatsoever
okay okay here's the ending okay
last point okay
scientists are building a black box to
record the end of civilization
i think there's a
feeling out there like a sixth sense
that lots of people have
that something is not right that we're
like close to the end of the world to
the end of a man extinction of man
and so we have all these theories about
extinction we have movies about
extinction we have
books written about it different
scenarios right
and these people developed a black box
what is this about well
the
the black box is going to supposedly
record
all the temperature the
[Music]
the economy
everything around us you know the
especially uh related to climate change
right so that when we're gone
you know the black box
records all this
and holds it for
for whom
well it holds it for a future generation
now it could be a future generation or
the klingons when they visit earth and
they say well what happened to these
humans you know and they look in the
record and say oh we found the black box
and the black box tells them oh this was
what happened towards the end okay and
again all these people are thinking of
climate primarily because you see there
it says um it's going to measure the
temperature energy you know and all this
other good stuff the
co2 levels and so on
uh
and so
they they thought about this black box
that's going to record all this
and one of the issues that this brings
up
was there ever a previous generation of
humans
or animals before
the
new
uh
like before the
pre-cambian cambrian or pre-cambrian was
there another era in which uh
there were humans for example or
or animals or plants
and will there be another one after
we're gone let's let's let's just
hypothesize right let's
say that humans are gonna become extinct
okay okay well let's make that
assumption
will there be some other generation of
humans that are born millions or
billions of years in the future
here on earth
or will the earth
uh
turn into
[Music]
a mars or venus type planet with just a
bunch of co2 no more life you know maybe
a runaway greenhouse effect kills
everything and then becomes a barren
stone that everything else is uh the
moon
uh mercury and so on
how are we gonna how is the earth gonna
end up
after the extinction of man
okay another question for you
okay let's get on with the subject
matter today and the subject matter is
power
what the hell is power
it turns out that power has something to
do with energy
and energy has something to do with mass
so we have all this connection there
right
um
i've held that no one has any idea what
energy is
okay and so let's begin there and let's
find out what energy is then maybe we
can find out if anyone knows what mass
is and i'm going to show that
according to some of the questions some
of the issues people raised some of the
comments people made
lots of people are still stuck on this
mass issue they have no idea what mass
is and if power depends on energy which
depends on mass
or they're all related somehow well the
question is whether we're going to learn
anything about power
okay so this is the subject matter today
so let's begin with an article that came
out okay the other day
and even though the article was
uh
brought up the other day in the
beginning of december first week of
december uh it dates the idea and the
really the original article dates for
about a year ago okay so it's
like one year old already but that's
irrelevant the point is what this uh
individual uh says what he states about
energy okay so let's begin there here we
have it paul says fragments of energy
not waves or particles
may be the fundamental building blocks
of the universe
he's a professor of mechanical aerospace
engineering in north carolina state
university larry silverberg
and this gentleman says that there's uh
something called energy out there
and it's these fragments the debris
of energy that makes up matter
it's not particles it's not waves as
you've always been told and remember
he's a phd right he's he's a professor
right
and the article says this file says
matter is what makes up the universe but
what makes up matter yeah a good
question what makes up matter i thought
it was atoms right and this file says my
colleague
jeffrey i should
and i have described an updated way to
think about matter whoa good
we propose that matter is not made of
particles or waves love that
what is it made out of it was long as
was long thought but more fundamentally
that matters made of fragments of energy
okay
and here it is if you always wanted to
know what energy looks like here we have
it okay i want you to see it
there it is
this is what he thinks
energy is these are the lines of energy
okay they swirl around i guess
and
he says new mathematics have shown that
the lines of energy can be used to
describe the universe
okay so
he's saying that what underlines all
matter is energy
do we know what energy is yeah that's
the question okay
and here you see uh
uh dynamic version of energy i want you
to be careful because it's gonna run
into your eyes there it is
okay you see all that energy just
flowing into your eyes okay
so this is what the universe is made out
of uh
i guess it's divided in two parts
uh the bottom half has the energy and
the top half has the uh
stars
this is how they conceptualize the
universe a little surrealistic but yeah
this is their vision of energy okay so
now you know what energy looks like what
it is and it's fragments of this
stuff that's flowing into your eyes so
that swirls around all these lines of
energy that's what makes up
uh matter
and so the question is what are these
lines of energy
are they physical entities
because i mean they draw them as lines
and whether they come into your eyes or
swirl around they're just lines
so
what are these lines i mean
forget about energy if
if energy is just a bunch of lines we
got to go to the line we got to go to
the bottom of the pile and find out you
know what makes up the energy what are
these lines it's like saying field what
is a field well field is this region
where we have numbers okay but then
numbers are not physical objects so
there's no physical object called field
and this is something similar if energy
is made out of all these swirling lines
or
lines just come straight into your eyes
or whatever what are the lines forget
about energy we need to figure out what
the lines are okay
uh like you know you have a magnetic
field again uh lines of force we need to
find out what those lines of force are
forget about the field the field is a
bunch of lines of force
now we need to figure out what the lines
are
that's the way it works in science and
physics okay you can't just say well
there's just a bunch of lines of force
and we just use them
to describe the field or or something in
there no no we gotta get to the bottom
of it we gotta find out what those lines
of force are you have to find that
needle in the haystack okay that's the
way it works anyways uh we don't have to
go too far and i've shown this before we
have mr fireman he says it is important
to realize that in physics today we have
no knowledge of what energy is
okay so he's saying he doesn't know what
energy is obviously energy is not a what
it's not a thing
because energy is defined as a concept
defined as capacity
uh the ability
there's no physical stand-alone object
called
ability or capacity so that's where the
whole thing ends because you can't
define something as capacity and then
say you're going to move the capacity or
kick it around like if you kick the
something so either we have these lines
of energy which are some kind of i don't
know some string some
little thread of some kind right
or uh or we define the term and say you
know it's capacity it's a mathematical
concept and nothing but
one of the two and yeah because uh they
don't know what energy is and uh mr
feynman says well you know i can safely
say that nobody understands quantum
mechanics do not keep asking yourself if
you can't possibly avoid it but how can
it be like that nobody knows how it can
be like that the more you see how
strangely nature behaves the harder it
is to make a model that explains how
even those simplest phenomena
actually were so theoretical physics has
given up
on that okay
tremendous statement from uh a nobel
prize winner in
so-called mathematics mathematical
physics so yeah we don't have any idea
what energy is because energy is not a
what energy is a mathematical concept
and if it's a concept it's not a thing
it's not a standalone thing and so this
other fellow who uh professor whatever
who says that
matter is made out of fragments of
energy well you know that really
stretches the imagination because here
we have a nobel prize that i'm sure
outranks this professor this good
professor and tells them that there is
no such thing as energy and if you don't
know what energy is and you're gonna
explain everything with energy
then we have a problem and the problem
is what uh feynman just said nobody
understands quantum mechanics
no kid
you know if you want to understand it at
least define your terms
or separate the objects from the
concepts and say look this is an object
and this is concept
so if you're going to talk about an
object illustrate it point to it
name it
if you're going to talk about a concept
define it that's how simple it is but if
you don't have a definition and you say
well it's a physical object but i can't
illustrate it because it's the capacity
then we have a problem of course he's
not going to understand anything about
the universe because mathematical
physics already has the seeds of its own
destruction its foundations are rotten
to the core that's what happens
and so what happens well
it turns out energy is just another form
of mass
oh my god so we don't know what energy
is
now uh now we're going to get to
mass
are we going to find out what mass is if
if if mass is just a for another form of
energy
well we don't know what energy is it's
not a what it's a concept and now we're
going to figure out what mass is is mass
a physical object is it a concept is it
a mathematical concept what is mass
and i tried to explain a little bit
about mass in the last few
lectures but some people are very hard
at hearing
they're very hard of understanding and
so uh
let's let's see if we can go through
some of this again and i'm sorry for
those people who have to put up with all
this
uh but i need to clarify some points so
that um
you know that people uh
at least find out what the arguments are
okay
mass is a big word so we so is energy we
and force field those are very big words
in mathematical physics we need to
destroy them we need to utterly destroy
them because people have the idea that
these are physical standalone objects
that they can move around they talk
about moving the mass and transferring
the energy and stretching the field or
vibrating the field you can't do that
because our these are mathematical
concepts
okay and so you know people have these
lousy notions in their head because this
is what they were brainwashed this is
what they
learned by wrote in high school
primarily in high school and then later
on reinforced in college okay i know
because i took a lot of college physics
courses and uh
and it was driven deep inside me and i
didn't you know come up to speed until
later on when i got out of college
that's when i started doing research
okay so here one file says mass is a
measure of how much matter
what
how many atoms right he clarifies that
masses that measure how much matter
there is in an object how many atoms
okay keep that in mind
the amount of matter it contains is
measured on a scale okay
we can then calculate a very close
approximation of how many atoms there
are
k is known as a mole
hey fine so we can calculate how many
atoms there are if mass
is how many atoms
his own words right
then uh all he's got to do is uh state
mass in terms of
how many atoms okay
according to his own definition this
requires him to state his results in
terms of how many atoms you cannot say
that mass is one kilogram
you gotta say mass is 500 um
atoms or 500 units of mass or whatever
you want to call it okay but he's got to
state his
his how many atoms in terms of a number
followed by units or atoms or whatever
because that's his definition that's his
notion
so he can't say uh mass is one kilogram
that's my point okay you gotta state it
in number of atoms which is what he's
stating is the definition okay so uh
we know now what mass is mass is the
quantity of matter and it should be
stated in number of apples and not in
kilograms of apples
okay um
continuously says when you drop
something from a height onto a scale it
has an acceleration
that is weight
okay so you're saying way to something
dynamic you're dropping it as it falls
we call that weight that's what he's
saying
when it hits the scale that is mass
okay so um hits the scale means now it's
stay there okay it's pressing down on
the scale the scale goes no further
we have a static situation and he's
going to call that one mass which again
what are we talking about quantity of
matter which is what he said before how
many atoms
that's mass okay and what he's saying is
that wait is something dynamic okay that
as the elephant falls
uh that's weight because that's the pull
of gravity on the
object
whereas that once it hits the scale and
moves no more now it's
standing still essentially with respect
to the scale now we call that mass
because
uh we can say well that's one kilogram
that's his notion so mass is quantity of
matter we're essentially measuring by
saying kilograms how many atoms the
thing has whereas weight is the pull of
gravity
and of course the pull of gravity is
different on the moon
for the same object than it is here on
the earth okay
so
that's the difference they want to give
you the notion that the mathematicians
from newton all the way to today to
stephen hawking and
passing through einstein all these
people have the same notion
okay
so they uh
i just want you to understand what they
understood by mass and weight and the
example always given
is that if you take whatever weight here
on earth say the
le grand kilo
used to be the standard of the kilogram
if you took that grand colo
right kilo to uh
the moon
it would have a different weight because
the pull of gravity on the moon is
different than
uh here on earth
and therefore the weight
changed
but the mass the number of atoms
remain the same
do we understand each other okay we're
saying that the elephant
um
that's falling there he would wait
different on the moon
the acceleration of gravity on him would
be different even though the guy is the
same guy that's sitting on the scale on
the right hand side
the number of atoms that comprise them
are just the same
nothing has changed in destruction the
number of atoms that the elephant has
i hope i'm getting through to someone
out there okay
okay so this is the notion okay
and then again we have some people out
there who don't have share this notion
or learn something different at their
monastery okay here we have paul says
mass isn't the quantity of atoms in an
object
okay so we have a different opinion here
this guy went to a different school i
guess okay
it is the quality of matter
that resists changes in its momentum
well now first of all nothing in
mathematics is qualitative and mass is
considered a quantitative uh both mass
and
weight are considered quantitative
parameters they're not qualitative at
all okay but this guy raises the issue
that it's the quality of matter some
some kind of quality so he says no one
is claiming that the number of atoms in
an object moving at an appreciable
fraction of the speed of light is going
up
okay so what are they saying says that
quality of all atoms
in that object is increasing
okay so this is another version
you can see uh people are very mixed up
on what mass is and of course when you
define mass and say it's the quantity of
matter some people don't like it because
it destroys their religion what is what
is it specifically destroying well it's
destroying einstein's notion that if an
object moves close to the speed of light
that's what special relativity says
mass
increases
known as relativistic mass right
relativistic mass is an object that
accelerates
usually in the in the context of special
relativity
accelerates at near the speed of light
and as it approaches the speed of light
its mass increases
so once again what increased
the number of atoms which is the rest
mass or is it the weight
how how much it presses up against the
scale
okay
which one is mass
these are two different notions
and we usually weigh a person and say oh
this is your weight
and they say well that's the
uh
notion of ordinary speech that's the
popular notion it's not the real super
duper scientific notion
okay let's find out
let's keep going let's see if we can get
to the bottom of this weight mass
dichotomy okay here it is
we have uh
foul says weight is a force
okay okay let's find out which is a
vector
we're going to get into that in a little
while but vector essentially is that
little arrow that the mathematicians
draw which has magnitude and direction
direction being a qualitative
concept okay direction there's no phys
there's no uh number you can put for
direction you can't say five and
understand or five units of whatever and
think that that's got direction of any
kind in fact that's exactly the opposite
when you have five followed by a unit
that's usually a scalar what is known as
a scalar and he
says that there he says it has magnitude
and direction and mass on the other hand
is a scalar
so what are we saying here we're saying
that in the first case we're talking
about gravitational pull
okay
and that's what force is using newton's
uh equation of force right
weight is a force according to this
fellow meaning it's dynamic
okay because force is dynamic
okay
and uh mass on the other hand is a
scalar
meaning it has no direction
okay so one has direction the other one
doesn't
okay
what is weight weight is the action of
gravity on an object
that's what newton's equation says
okay
but
is it is it a force first of all
or is it a tension
and i'm saying it's not a force it's a
tension and tension is not a force
tension no one wins the tug of war
tension does not have direction
force is a vector has direction tension
does not
okay so the question is that equation
there mass mass divided by distance
squared okay
does that have direction
and the answer no
what we have right there is a static
situation where we have two masses the
earth
and the moon we take a snapshot of that
it's a snapshot right there it's a
static situation no motion and at that
point we have weight
what is weight there you have the
equation
the separation between two objects we're
taking a snapshot to calculate that
value
called weight
okay
and what we have is just distance
between them separation not distance
traveled no one's traveling nothing's
moving it's a snapshot it's a static
situation all we have is a separation
between the center of mass right of the
two objects
all we have is distance not distance
traveled okay
and uh that's the calculation
okay so that is a tension that's not a
force because there is no motion
there is no uh vector
there is no direction to tension it's
just
a static situation think of it as a
dumbbell okay
two
weights separated by a stick made of a
single piece that's tension when you
pull the rubber band to a maximum
that you can stretch it
that's the maximum tension that's called
tension when you can't move it any
further okay so the maximum stretch on a
rubber band will call that tension you
can't move it any further
and it's like if you had
something separating for example your
two fingers with that's made of a single
piece that's what it amounts to that's
what tension is and that's what that
equation says
there's only distance
separation between two objects
okay so um
it's a weight is not a force then
not according to that equation
okay because that's not a vector
the other uh equation newton's second
law that is a force because there is
direction in that equation there is no
direction in this equation of force
which is not force
which is tension and that's what weight
is it's a value for a given location
weight is location specific okay
and uh so here we have
another uh situation that clarifies this
we have newton's gravitational equation
states that you have weight before
anything is accelerated okay
uh weight is location specific and
location is a static concept okay that's
what the equation says weight meaning
tension is separation between two masses
that's how it is and all we're saying is
that the astronaut there he weighs 100
kilograms on earth
you take them a little farther back out
and for a given location no motion
snapshot okay
separation
he weighs now 50 kilograms at that
location
if he moves a millimeter he's gonna have
a different weight
so again low weight is location specific
you move a farther out he weighs only 25
kilograms at that location he moves an
inch
all bets are off he just no longer
weighs 25 kilograms he may weigh 25.1 or
or 24.9
no longer does he weigh 25 kilograms
only for a given location with respect
to the center of the
mass of the earth right does he have 25
kilograms
okay do we understand that and the only
way you can explain that is here's the
uh
illustration for that okay
is because
uh all the ropes and here we uh are
converging upon him from the earth every
atom on earth is bound to every atom in
his body
so as he is closer to the earth the rose
fan out
and so he has more weight he has a
greater acceleration towards the earth
at that location again it's an
acceleration but
we're talking about a given
location in which that uh 50 kilograms
is valid for example or at the 25
kilograms is valid once he's closer to
the earth obviously he has a different
weight okay the only way you can explain
this is if every atom in his body is
bound to every atom on earth first of
all second you can see that in this case
i've only put one atom connected to
every atom on earth or even too many
atoms not even to every atom because you
know you wouldn't see anything if i put
all the
connections there but you can see what's
happening
you have more ropes fanning out as you
approach the earth that's what it's all
about and that explains weight
and shows that weight is location
specific okay so
uh yeah the point here is that
weight is not something dynamic
weight is location specific and what
that means is that uh it's a static
concept
you know a weight is not something
dynamic you don't have to put something
on a scale except in
all these experimentalists who think
that it's a question of pressing down on
the scale
that's how we measure weight and mass
both of them we measure them by weighing
them right whether here or on the moon
and if uh conceptually mass is the
quantity of matter we have no idea how
many atoms it has which is the way you
would have to specify your result of
mass you would have to say
say
500 trillion atoms
then that would be mass that's the way
you would have to specify mass
you can say mass is measured and mass is
one kilogram no that's known as weight
okay
and now let's do a little thought
experiment
that clarifies i think even further this
whole thing
um
you know einstein said that if you
travel close to the speed of light
okay
your mass increases
you say well hold it what do you mean
mass increases
am i gaining more pounds
meaning
am i weighing more
am i having more atoms
which would be mass
or am i just weighing more because
as you fall for example towards a an
object towards a celestial object say
you're falling towards a star
right
well you your accel you're accelerating
because
gravity is something that accelerates
you towards the center of that object
right so you're accelerating you're
accelerating now let's say at close to
the speed of light
did you gain more pounds did you gain
more atoms or is it simply that your uh
weight increases that the acceleration
of gravity on your
atoms
is what producing this acceleration this
speed this increase in speed as you fall
towards the object
okay so here let's illustrate what i'm
saying here okay with
uh
pictures worth a thousand words where a
movie is worth a million words okay so
let's go with a movie okay so we saved a
lot here
here we have two objects okay they're
exactly alike it's the same object on
the right and on the left okay
and um they have the same number of
atoms
but as you can see the one on the left
is uh accelerating faster than the one
on the right
and that's because the object on the
star okay in this case the one on the
left has more mass okay it's got more
atoms therefore it's producing an
acceleration on the object uh that
makes it go uh
at 99
of the speed of light and the other one
uh almost the same but not quite it's 95
of the speed of light okay
so the only difference here is not the
two objects that are falling the
difference here is just the object
that's underneath okay the the star in
this case and think of it again as uh
the moon you know if you take the grand
pilot
from here to the moon it's going to have
a different acceleration
so even though it's at the same distance
from the ground
that it was here on earth it falls at a
different rate because the acceleration
of gravity over there is different okay
so that's what i'm illustrating here so
we have one acceleration uh that forces
this object to travel near the speed of
light at 99 percent
of the speed of light the other one uh
is falling at 95 percent of the speed of
light the objects are the same they have
the same number of atoms okay
so uh is einstein going to say that this
is relativistic mass
or is are we talking about weight here
because this is what they illustrate
when they say look this is weight the
mass is the same but when you take it to
the moon
it the mass remained the same but the
weight changed okay so now we have that
situation here are we talking about
relativistic mass or are we talking
about weight
this is the question
and of course uh this is something that
einstein never figured out
in fact no mathematician figured out
that what they're talking about is
weight so whenever they refer to
relativistic mass what they're really
talking about is weight
we're saying that if an object falls at
99
uh speed of light in the other one 95
percent of the speed of light
they're tying up towards an object the
celestial object they're talking about
weight
they're not talking about relativistic
mass whatever mass is they just created
this
unnecessary concept called relativistic
mass
to say that an object accelerates when
it goes near the speed of light
yeah it's known as weight we've known
that
for many years now okay and i guess mr
eine never figured that out he wasn't
smart enough
okay so we don't know what energy is
mass is another form of energy we don't
know what mass is because
mass is uh measured
that's how we determine mass we don't
illus we don't
give our results in terms of quantity of
atoms we give it in terms of kilograms
which is a measurement and not counting
there's a difference between measuring
and counting so we don't know what
energy is we don't know what mass is
turns out power the subject matter today
has something to do with energy which
has something to do with mass
so i'm sorry to tell you that we're
going to be in deep trouble today we
won't know what power is but let's give
it our best shot let's see if we can get
to the bottom of power which is another
important parameter that they use in
mathematics known as mathematics or some
some people know as mathematical
so-called physics
okay here it is uh we went through these
uh different parameters force mass
weight acceleration distance traveled
which is not the same thing as distance
okay distance in physics is separation
distance traveled is uh
a parameter that belongs exclusively to
mathematical physics because they're
going to put a number for that they're
going to tell you in
meters or in seconds how far you went
etc you know so distance traveled is a
measure of mathematics it has nothing to
do with physics physics separation
that's qualitative physics is 150
qualitative nothing but okay we don't
use numbers in physics
okay velocity speed what was the
difference well velocity has direction
uh speed doesn't okay
but then uh we have the problem when you
turn a corner they want to talk about
velocity and they say well the velocity
change well what do you mean the
velocity change did the direction change
uh yeah
the speed remained the same but the
direction changed
but direction is a qualitative concept
and so we have a problem there because
that doesn't belong to mathematics okay
so we have a problem with velocity okay
anyways uh it's again a parameter that
belongs exclusively to mathematical
physics it doesn't belong to science or
to physics physics we're interested in
explanations and not in measurements or
quantitative values of any kind
work energy and temperature today we do
power okay well let's see what power is
let's find out let's one good way of
getting to the bottom of that is finding
out
what the definition of power is let's
find out the definition here it is power
the amount of energy energy
that spirit
transferred
or converted
per unit time and there you have one
equation
you would think it's the only equation
you're going to be surprised
okay so what is it uh power is equal to
energy divided by time straight forward
easy stuff
just memorize it and
take the test on friday and you you
won't have any problem you won't get
hurt
okay but what are we talking about in
terms of physics what is this well
energy is the capacity the ability
okay that's the definition of that so
that's what you put
we got to put the word capacity on top
of uh where the e is right
what is the little t well that's time
what is time is what a clock measures
okay that's very uh
important because clock is what a device
that measures time so we we seem to have
a circular
definition or argument here i mean what
have we learned with this
power equals energy divided by time we
have no idea what energy is we really
don't have what an idea what time is
there's no definition uh mathematicians
tell you they don't know what time
is and then uh you have these
definitions are which are circular
so so far you know
it's like a son comes home and says
father says
uh hey samso what did you learn in
college today i said well not much there
not much
all i did was learn that p is equal to e
over t okay great memorize it and you're
done you know okay and so uh it turns
out that um
we have more equations for this same
parameter we thought that power was
energy over time
uh transfer of energy conversion of
energy whatever
and now we find out that it's also a
force multiplied by speed
velocity
in parenthesis okay this is not my i
took this out of there okay uh
from someone else okay so this is from
the uh
phds okay and there's your equation p
equals force times velocity
okay so that's a little different than
uh e over t now we have
f times v
okay little v okay big f times v okay
does it stop there no uh power is also w
over delta t
what is
uh the w its work and what is the delta
t elapsed time
and then you find
other forms of power other flavors okay
electric power what is that well that's
uh p
is equal power equal to
v times i voltage times intensity of
current or intensity squared times
resistance or
v squared over r the uh voltage over a
squared over resistance
so we have all these equations they're
all power
what the hell is power i mean
which one of these will the real power
please stand up
okay we have all these versions of power
i'm lost already you know i i wanted to
get to the bottom of power but all i do
all i have is all these versions of
power and they call every one of these
flavors they call them power
electric power and uh
uh
you know wattage power and the work
power and force power
they have all these powers okay
okay let's see if we can uh improve on
that it turns out it only gets worse
okay
says power is a scalar quantity
scalar what the hell is a scalar well
scalar is a physical quantity
a physical quantity
see it's not an abstract quantity it's a
real physical one that you can hold in
your hand it's a quantity that you know
you have there in your hands
that is completely described by its
magnitude
okay
no such monster in physics as a physical
quantity okay let's clarify that what is
a vector well it's kind of uh
something
extra and it's a geometric object that
says object
what do you mean an object geometric
object
vector is an object
i think they mean an arrow you know like
an engine arrow that you shoot
is that what an object is that's what a
vector is an arrow
yeah it's a geometric object no it's a
mathematical concept not a geometric
object no such thing as objects in
mathematics in mathematical physics okay
they have no objects they never define
the word object so they can't have
objects
with both length and direction okay
length and direction is not an object
length and direction do not
an object make
two concepts do not an object mate okay
so no uh if if
a vector's length and direction
magnitude and direction uh we still
don't have an object so don't call it an
object
and but the point here is that these two
notions are different scalar is a
quantity
and the other one is a quantity with
direction
that's the bottom line that's the
difference between a scalar and a vector
okay
okay and uh so let's continue let's find
out maybe we've learned something today
i don't know quantities such as force
and velocity have both magnitude and
direction and are called vectors okay
so here we have a scalar power is called
a scalar okay so so there right
what is this power equal to this scale
or equal to well it's equal to two
vectors
so we multiply two vectors in this
example
force which is a vector times velocity
which is a vector
and we end up with something that has no
direction a scalar
okay so when you multiply two vectors
that have direction you end up with
directionless
scalar
okay great yeah we learned a lot these
days okay let's find out if this is true
um because it says they're um examples
of scalars are volume density speed
energy mass and time okay now we know
those are all scalars
please memorize this for the test on
friday okay
what are the scalars
uh
volume density speed energy mass and
time
got it memorized them okay let's
continue let's find out okay let's find
out if this is true
and we look it up and it says
that time
has direction
it's got a little arrow there it's going
up you see you see time this is on the
this uh the light cone that they call in
mathematical physics is one of their uh
sacred icons you gotta pray to this
and it has time going up in a direction
in fact they talk about the arrow of
time and they talk about time having
direction and you're saying what do you
mean direction yeah it's a vector it's a
uh
coordinate it's got an arrow that's what
that arrow head points to you know it's
it's giving you direction and the
direction is forward
now is there such a thing as a forward
direction
okay
is this the issue
and um
you know who's forward you're forward or
my forward i mean what are we talking
about when we say forward and they say
well to the future
well is that a forward
what kind of direction is the future
point to it
okay
and then the other one is attention i
mean is tension a scalar
okay because uh again tension means that
you have a single
uh
piece uh thingy that's separating two
objects or you can say something
stretched to the limits which i'm again
is a static constant that's what tension
is nothing no one's winning the tug of
war nothing is moving under some
so-called tension
and so the question is is tension a uh a
scalar
or is it a vector
and again they say that tension is a
force
force is a vector
so are we going to say that tension is
also a vector
which direction is tension pointing to
which again takes us to weight which is
a tension which is valid for a single
point in space if you want to use it
that language
we say it's for a single location
okay with respect to all matter in the
universe
weight is only valid for a given
location in the universe once you move
that object it has different weight with
respect to every single object in the
universe
uh known as mach's principle you know
everything pulls on you
in the universe or you're bound to
everything in the universe
okay
so i think we're learning a little bit
about
maybe not about uh power because we
still have no idea what power is but
it's a scalar whatever that is okay
um
you know we have uh
this thing called power that has no
direction
but uh
they have all these other things that
have directions such as
tension which is supposedly a force
which has direction and time which they
say has direction but they say is a
scalar
so you try to figure it out okay
here's the conclusions okay that's all i
can give you today for power
use it in use it more likely in politics
than in physics okay because you're
never going to find out what power is
what are the conclusions okay power is
the transfer conversion of energy
according to their own words where
energy is an adjective or adverb
power is a scalar no direction
okay made of quantities like force and
velocity which have direction yeah you
can have uh different directions for
this and they could cancel out all that
stuff it doesn't matter my point is that
here you have
this thing power known as a scalar but
it also has the word
time in there which they say well it's a
scalar but it turns out time does have
direction according to mathematical
physics
and then you have weight
uh which again they say is a
is a force which is supposedly
a scalar but it turns out force
weight is attention and tension does not
have
direction
so
those are things that the mathematical
physicists never discovered because they
do equations but they don't understand
the concepts the physical concepts that
underlie the concepts that they created
for mathematics to do measurement
and numbers
okay power is made of time which the
mathematicians claim is a scalar
quantity but this one has direction okay
because they claim both that it's a
scalar but that it has direction so now
we don't even know what a scalar is
because a scalar supposedly is a number
without direction
and then like energy and mass there are
several types or flavors of power
so you figure out what power means or is
okay corollary power is another
convenient and powerful word of
mathematical physics mathematics right
that describes everything and explains
absolutely
nothing
okay
so i hope you learned what power is okay
now you can tell you're a little kid oh
i can tell you what power is
in politics
let's get to some of the
uh
questions commons people made had a lot
of them and a lot of them had to do with
the word object
remember what does bill gates say says
that the word object the definition of
the word object the scientific
the definition of physics right
of the word object destroys all
religions
that word is so powerful and of course
all these people rebel because
eventually they end up at the word
object also at the word exist by the way
and at that point they realize something
is wrong about their theory
because it turns out that they weren't
using objects they were using words such
as energy and field and mass
and they've treated them as objects they
reified them okay
turned them into something concrete
turns out they were talking about an
abstract mathematical concept
which they reified
and of course at that point they said
well no no we don't like that definition
and there's only one way to fight that
definition and it is coming up with a
definition you can defend if you cannot
defend your definition i'm sorry but
your religion dies right there and then
that's how we treat it in science
you may want to raise issues of
authority of democracy and say well
everybody on earth believes that it's
sea and touch
that's what authority says all these
nobel prize winners they say it's see
and touch the philosophers say that
tradition says it
we follow tradition no not in science in
science uh we have to define
in such a way that we can use it
consistently
and if you don't like the definition
because it destroys your religion you
have only one recourse and that's to get
inside the ring and fight for your
definition with shield and sword okay
okay so here it goes one file size
along these lines right
so speed is the time rate at which an
object is moving along a path while
velocity is the rate and direction and
objects of an object's movement
and another file says answers to him
says velocity doesn't make sense squared
yeah because uh what happens is uh
squaring direction doesn't have meaning
why because direction is a qualitative
concept what are you going to do with
direction are you going to
square squared are you going to say i'm
going to take the square root of
direction or
take it to the power of 3 or something
along those lines no are you going to
add direction
yeah we have a problem with
considering velocity because when you
square velocity
you're also squaring direction
and that's something the mathematicians
do all the time without paying attention
to direction except
when they say well the object turned the
corner now it's going around the earth
you know the earth is going around the
sun
so it's accelerating
uh what do you mean it's accelerating
uh the speed didn't change the earth
always travels at the same speed yeah
what change was the direction
what do you mean the direction well what
happened was this and again i've
illustrated that in the past let's go
over it again and switch over here
okay
here you have an object and uh what is
speed distance divided by time okay
but that's not the distance of physics
it's not separation we're talking about
distance traveled we're talking about a
number followed by units like meters or
feet or whatever
okay speed is quantitative but direction
is
qualitative
and
you can probably square the speed
no problem there but can you square
direction and why is that important well
because you have their velocity of
something that's going around in circles
when it goes straight no problem you
know because you're not paying attention
to direction you don't have to worry too
much about that it's when you have go to
go in circles because they say the speed
is the same
but the thing accelerated
even what do you mean i thought
acceleration was an increase in speed
and they say no when you go around in
circles like the mathematicians do
uh what changes a direction
which is a qualitative concept okay and
what are we talking about we're talking
about centripetal
acceleration anyways it's factored in
that change in direction so you're
you're factoring acceleration anyways in
there because that's what causes the
change in direction okay
but the question comes you know when you
try to
square these things when you square
velocity are you also squaring the
direction
when you do these calculations are you
squaring the qualitative
concept
same when you take the square root by
the way you know you're doing the same
thing in reverse and here we see it okay
here's a good old inez uh
notion okay and what is he saying he's
saying that uh a photon
uh
when it goes around a mass such as a
star
well it says that the mass of the star
bends space time warp space time and the
poor little photon has no choice but to
turn the corner there you know swerves
around right it changes its direction
because of mass because
it it it rolls around space time so to
speak or slides along space time warp
space time and so
it once it goes straight but somehow
it's uh it finds the this curved wall
along which it has to travel that's the
notion they have so yeah the little
photon is a little mass i guess or a
massless mass
that um uh can be conserved so it
doesn't go straight
okay
it swerves it changes its direction
and so the question is uh you know when
they do a
squaring of velocity like velocity of
light
and light turns a corner or swerves like
it did there it deflects from its
rectilinear path
are you squaring
the direction also
a qualitative concept
i'll let you think about that one and
it's beyond my intelligence
i don't have an iq of 200 like this guy
had i only have one of like 10 or 20 you
know i'm very modest
okay little brain you know okay
calculating work on an incline plane so
the guy sends me to a link says this
shows why we don't have to deal with the
angle in the calculation okay
calculation of work remember work equals
force times distance and we're saying
that's force times distance times
the cosine of the angle alpha or
whatever theta and why because it's not
the same thing to have a force on a
horizontal plane than it is going up a
mountain so you need to know that angle
to find out you know um what the force
is going to be not going to be the same
force going pushing a box
straight ahead assuming there's no
friction for example to make things easy
then pushing it up a mountain
okay same distance but the force is
different that you have to apply to
something going up
this guy hasn't figured that out okay
and so we have to clarify it for him
here it is okay
uh this if you go to that site you find
this simple machines incline plane and
this vowel makes the same error maybe he
just wasn't aware of what he was doing
he says work is uh force times distance
okay
fine but you can see the force changes
from the
purple on the left to the blue light
blue on the right he's got 200 newtons
in one case and he's got 40 newtons in
another
and that's not what we're talking about
we're talking about the same distance
first of all okay
one on an incline plane the other one is
in a horizontal plane
and then uh if we're going to leave the
force
uh exactly the like in both cases 200
newtons
times six meters well we're not going to
have the same work
uh if you go up the mountain than if you
go on a horizontal plane
okay so yeah the equation does have to
have this uh
cosine because you have to know what the
angle is in order to calculate the force
the force is going to be
different it's factored in those 200
newtons or in in whatever force you got
there the reason you see that there's a
change in force from 40 newtons to 200
newtons is because the angle is already
included in that value that's what's
happened there okay
and uh this falls uh hasn't figured that
out so he
has the wrong um
notion
we're we're not talking about change in
uh
in the force
we're saying for the same force same
distance it's not the same thing as
going up a mountain is going straight
that's what we're saying and the example
he showed there has nothing to do with
that okay it's a totally different
example
okay another fellow says
heat is a form of ether
i don't know what ether this guy's
smelling lately but uh i don't know it
says bouncing particles nope
okay let's find out uh here's the ether
okay defined
ether according to and these are
definitions you'll find out there the
material that fills region of the
universe beyond the terrestrial sphere
okay this is what the greeks thought of
the ether this is out of wikipedia i
think
and there's another one notion and this
is the 19th century notion which they
used to talk about light the motion of
what light was okay the vibration of the
ether says the postulated medium for the
propagation of light the existence of an
invisible and infinite what material
with no interaction with physical
objects so we're talking about a
material
is this material made of a single piece
well i don't think so because if this
material were made out of a single piece
meaning there is no space in there in
between there's
just a single
rock a single block
nothing would be moving
there would be no vibration of any
internal part because it's made out of a
single piece therefore this material is
obviously made of parts which are
vibrating means each little part each
little particle is surrounded by space
which is what the this little particle
can move into because there's nothing
there
so this infinite material is made of
little particles of parts of segments
however you want to call it i'll call it
particles how's that we're saying that
this thing they call ether is a bunch of
particles that's all it is
they want to say it's infinite find it
you don't want to say it's finite that's
fine i don't care either way the point
is that this ether is made of particles
and these people never figured it out
yeah they are bouncing particles and
here you have mr robert laughlin and
he's a nobel laureate and he says the
following says the modern concept of the
vacuum of space confirmed every day by
experiment is a relativistic ether but
we do not call it this because it is
taboo
they all called it uh
i was cut off there i think uh by
youtube i hope i'm still here
they said they reconnected me okay fine
uh anyway let me repeat what i just said
just in case
um
einstein all these people they had an
ether
everybody
we've never abandoned mathematical
physics has never abandoned the ether
from the days of newton from the days of
descartes uh going all the way to plato
no one has ever done anything except the
ether they always considered space
to be filled with a bunch of particles
that bunch of particles each particle
surrounded by space by nothing is what
that whole bunch of particles is what
they call ether here it is illustrated
for anyone who has uh who wants us to
know what ether looks like okay here's
what the ether looks like now this is a
finite ether
other people have an infinite ether
whatever that is
particles extending forever
but that's what the ether was in the
19th century and still is today
the vibration of
photons
is the vibration of a bunch of particles
known that form the ether in the
background
and it's those same particles which the
mathematicians claim to
produce in the labs
positive and negative
they bring them into existence again
meaning that they bring them out of
space
empty space so so-called empty space
which is not empty at all it's got all
this energy all these particles and all
these particles are vibrating you pull
one of those particles from space
of which space is made right and you
turn them into two particles one
positive one negative
so yeah the ether has never been
abandoned by mathematical physics
everybody thinks
that space is made of particles
and that's what the ether has always
been
so anyone who has a different definition
don't tell me i'm wrong
okay that's not the answer the answer is
tell me what's right what do you think
is the ether define the word ether
and hopefully you don't define it
because that automatically makes it into
a concept
hopefully you can draw it and point to
it and say this is the ether like i did
there more or less except that an object
is not a bunch of particles an object is
that which has shape and um so if you
say that that whole shebang that i just
showed is the ether fine because you can
point to it and say this is where it
ends we'll call that
bundle of gas which is what it looks
like a bunch of particles floating
around in space if you call that the
ether then treat the whole ether as a
thing and not tell me that there's a
part of it that vibrates and that's
light
now that's that's not what the ether is
either is the whole thing if you're
going to say the ether vibrate you're
vibrating the whole elephant
not the little
atoms that
of which the elephant is comprised
okay so we have to understand the
context here okay the context is
if you're gonna talk about the gas like
air
and you say the air in the balloon
okay that's an object why is it an
object because it's made out of
particles no it's because you treat the
whole gas as a single blob
okay and so you re release it in space
all these atoms
and you'll say air you point to and say
air
let's assume you can see it color coded
whatever
so you point to that whole blob and you
call that air or gas or whatever you
want word you want to use no problem you
can call it x if you want
okay and that is a object and you got to
treat it as a single object you can't
say well you know these particles that
make up the air that's the air no no
that's uh
meteorology that's what something is
made out of and that's not what a thing
is what an object is an object is that
which has shape you got to treat the
whole thing
and the same thing here okay so uh if
the ether
is this gas made of particles
uh fine we don't care we're gonna look
at the whole thing
and say this is the ether the whole
thing the bunch of the the whole shape
if it's an object if you're gonna say
well it's a bunch of these little
particles that move
that's not an object
now you got to talk about the particles
not about the ether
either the whole shebang the whole
elephant not what it's made of
i hope somebody
understood okay here we have another
issue moving on temperature is a measure
of the average kinetic energy of the
particles in a system and you haven't
said anything because we don't know what
energy is okay
type of energy associated with motion
yeah we don't know what energy is in
fact mathematical physics hasn't defined
the word motion so until you define
energy
and motion we have no idea what you're
talking about especially if you're going
to define energy if you're going to
define energy means you
energy is not a physical object so we
can't talk about the motion of a concept
okay so you can't talk about the motion
of energy okay there's no such monster
okay
okay but he says the photoelectric
effect is when
electrically charged particles are
released from or within a material an
ejection of electrons when light falls
on it red light will not eject electrons
violet light will eject many electrons
well uh
before you can get that far
before you can make that statement
you got to draw the atom for us we need
to see what your atom looks like okay
because you're using the planetary model
of the atom which
nobody believes and everybody debunks it
but that's what you're saying when
you're saying that it's a flow of
electron particles of electrons
you can't say that until you draw your
atom
and so if that's your atom there a
little
bead that rolls around the nucleus
uh you got to justify that atom and the
main thing you have to justify is what
keeps that electron bead rolling around
faithfully around the
proton bowling ball or the nucleus or
whatever you want to call it why does it
spontaneously fly away
why does it stay within
certain
energy levels as they're called or
orbitals why doesn't it spontaneously
just fly away why does it gain
independence of its own volition
right
so unless you can justify your atom you
can't make that statement that's a
so far an irrational statement because
it's an unjustified statement
okay another fellow also talks about the
photoelectric effect and he says you are
unfair and in contradiction with your
own proposal of science oh okay let's
see einstein has given both description
and explanation of the photoelectric
effect
or has he
by saying that quantum of light photons
are this and they do so etc
he gave an explanation
the question is did you get it do you
understand it if so then the rational
science session is over nobody tells you
to believe it or not
okay what's the issue the issue is that
they give an irrational explanation
an irrational explanation is no
explanation at all so the answer to this
is no einstein did not give an
explanation for the photoelectric effect
not because i i don't believe in it but
because it's irrational because he
doesn't have an atom
we need an atom
and until you can draw the atom you
don't have an explanation a mechanism of
how the photoelectric effect or what
underlies the photoelectric effect the
photoelectric effect supposedly
according to einstein according to all
these bean brains from quantum mechanics
is that the electron bead i'm sorry the
photon
uh hits the electron bead and knocks it
out
and the flow of all these electron beads
is what they call electricity so they
say well when you shine light on
polished metal well they have all these
beads flowing that's called current and
so light
induces
electrons to flow electricity
current
well before you can say all that first
you got to draw your photon got to find
out what a photon is proton originates
in an atom
according to quantum mechanics and so
you got to find tell us how that photon
is created i mean does it shoot
infinite
photons in atom
that's the first issue what does it look
like is it a little ball and then this
photon hits the electron
which is rolling around an atom
and you're going to explain your you got
to justify your atom again you know you
got to draw the atom and if you draw the
planetary atom which is the one they're
probably gonna that's the one that
einstein used he says you know the
photon is hitting
the electron beat and knocking it out of
its orbit and now it starts flowing as
electricity okay you got to draw your
atom and unless you can do that you
don't have a rational
explanation
so it's not a question of belief it's
that he can't make sense
of his explanation that's the issue okay
so no einstein does not have an
explanation for the photoelectric effect
what he has in it is an equation a
description and nothing but
okay
another fellow again all these
issues come back to the word object to
the word thing what is a thing okay
and if i says you're insisting on shape
that which has a single boundary
absolutely not
okay
now
shape is not that which has a single
boundary
in fact
fell says boundary is left undefined but
can be put into everyday speech as where
the shape ends
so we have like uh
you know um
circular argument uh it's a single
boundary what's a boundary it's uh where
the shape ends what is shape
where the boundary ends
or what's what is contained within a
boundary or whatever you know so
these people are idiots okay and what is
an idiot okay idiot is a guy with big
ideas
see
normal people rational people they have
ideas
but an idiot has a big idea it's known
as ideolot
big idea ideot and so we call them
idiots okay and yeah so the
anyone who
looks for the word shape tries to define
the word shape is an idiot he's got big
ideas
an object is then treat a synonym of
shape again not because an object is a
noun
it's a category
okay it's a
grammatical category where a shape is an
adjective a qualifier of a noun
okay so a shape is not a noun in physics
okay and until you get that through your
skull you know uh well you remain an
idiot okay so yeah
please do not ask
about shape okay
and um here's an example of idiots okay
other people who ask
stupid questions okay
uh and by the way uh the the issue with
uh shape is context and again these
people never learned that
uh we have to define the word object not
the word shape and the word object is a
problem because if we don't define it as
that which has shape then it defaults to
c and touch
which is an irrational
uh definition of the word object we
can't use the words the the notion
of object b and c
touch in science in physics
in great measure because you need two
objects one to do the seeing and the
touching the other one is that you're
not talking about um
you know you have to define the word
object before you define motion of such
a seeing and touching
and there's a lot of arguments against
the c touch
definition therefore we can't use that
one on the other hand shape is a
universal
property of all objects so shape is the
scientific definition you don't like the
definition because it destroys your
religion very simple get in the ring
bring your definition and defend it
don't tell me authority don't tell me
democracy don't tell me tradition none
of that
okay you gotta defend
the rational definition that you propose
if it's rational
and
you know nobody does that they just want
to say well we've done this all
forever so who are you bill to tell us
that this is something else i'm not
telling you i'm saying i'm defining the
word
object as that which has shape
that's what it is for physics you don't
like it get in the ring and fight for
your definition and attack mine i have
no problem people attacking my
definition but you got to put something
in exchange because we can't do physics
physical interpretations without an
object you need the word
object and physic you need to define it
somehow
okay as well says if temperature is rope
how does something like laser cooling
work whoa that blew my mind i need a
beer to understand the question also why
do states of material change with
temperature
and another foul says it's time a
physical quantity
a physical quantity or just another
spirit as you call them where are the
time rows
now you see why these people are idiots
okay yeah we have a little bit of
problem with some of these folks
move on see if uh we have a little
better uh
questions or comments but now you'll
find out that we have a lot of
irrational comments uh this time around
a lot of them have to do with the word
object or thing
paul says a field is a mathematical
representation okay mathematical
representation great it's constant okay
we see
whether weather fields all the time
[Laughter]
so he sees these concepts these
mathematical concepts i guess uh in his
dreams or when he shoots up i don't know
temperature is a measure of the average
kinetic energy of the particles in a
system
again we don't know what energy is okay
please uh physics use uh math all the
time yeah and that's why they have no uh
understanding of physics okay uh
he's really referring to mathematical
physicists okay and so yeah physics does
not use math at all physics is entirely
qualitative we have to explain how this
universe works we need to explain the
mechanisms such as you know gravity and
magnetism
uh
says every quantity has shape another
now quantity has shape
what are these people onto a bartender i
want to have whatever he had you know
frequency is a shape
uh idiots yes absolutely if you don't
believe it put your hand on the stove
while it is on high
uh these people think that exp they
choose whether heat for example right
is a physical object and they say it is
because if you put the hand in the stove
the heat will burn your hand
and i had a similar
type of argument from the electric
universe again a bunch of what idiots
and what did the idiots of the electric
universe say well they say that
i said that electricity is not a
physical object electricity is a concept
known as current
uh even under quantum mechanics the flow
of electron beads fine we'll accept it
no problem that's a concept
the electron bead you can say is a
physical object you cannot say that the
flow
of electron beads
electricity current whatever you want to
call it is an object
and these people say well if you want to
see if it's an object stick your fingers
into the outlet and find out and you'll
see what zaps you that's an object
that's electricity
so in these people the same thing they
have the this irrational reasoning if
you can call it reasoning where they say
heat is an object oh it's a physical
yeah because you put your hand in the
fire and it burns your hand so the heat
burn your hand
this is their logic
or your logic
okay this is their way of thinking this
is or lack of
okay here's another
says theoretical and mathematical
physics employs mathematical models
methods suitable for the formulation of
theories
and abstractions of physical objects
abstractions of physical object what the
hell is that
to explain
natural phenomena well how do you
explain natural phenomena if you're not
going to put an object i mean it's
either an abstract
abstraction a concept meaning right
either it's a concept or an object you
can't have it both ways either it has
shape or doesn't have shape black or
white god cannot be both either god has
shape and as a human being with hands
and so on or god is love god is
intelligence concepts
and if that's what you pray to a concept
you know to
love fine and that's i hope love answers
you i hope love has ears right
um
foul says
math fizz doesn't explain
uh oh this is the donald simonek okay
and he says mathis doesn't explain math
is describes so no when he's this far
says that to explain natural phenomena
no uh mathematical physics does not
explain anything it has only irrational
explanations with quotations meaning no
explanation at all this is like saying
in in the old days with traditional
religions they would say that the spirit
or the soul does this and that
that's not an explanation
okay that's not an explanation
explanation is a mechanism that you have
to explain why the curtain moved what
moved the curtain and you cannot say a
spirit moved the curtain
because the spirit is not a physical
object the soul the soul moved
the curtain and this is no different
when you say that mass did this and the
energy did then the field did this and
time did that
you're not explaining anything
you're describing mathematically but you
turn that into a physical interpretation
which it ain't
so yeah at least donald simone
apparently seems to
insinuate that there's a difference
between an explanation and a description
because he says you know mathis does not
explain
it describes so yeah this file is wrong
there is no explanation of natural
phenomena in all of mathematical physics
okay so uh do not confuse an explanation
with a description
okay another follow says lots of
questions this time around uh
mathematical physics also known as man
is mathematics right uses experimental
tools to prove natural physical
phenomena with concern on experiments
and observation yeah that's what
mathematical physics does mathematics is
experiments and observation
and uh he says physics follows the
scientific method absolutely yeah no
doubt about it and here's a scientific
method for those of you who want to come
in contact with it there's a rational
scientific method what we call it right
hypothesis these are the assumptions
that you need to propose in order to
give a physical interpretation to a
phenomenon and you have to present the
objects point to them
you better have solid definitions
meaning words that can be used
consistently and you have to have the
initial scene or the first few frames of
the film that
essentially are the statements of the
facts according to you
the ones you're going to use to prop up
your theory what's the theory the
mechanisms and the causes okay so that
is
the scientific method so yeah physics
does follow the scientific method so
he's right about that now here's an
example of why we don't do mathematical
physics meaning mathematics meaning that
we don't do these things
in
in physics okay what is it
according to mathematical physics they
go out there and they do experiments and
then they do observations and here's one
good example the gravity probe b
experiment that was done in sub 2004 a
little price tag of 750 million that
came out of your pocket if you're a
taxpayer right
and what they did with this experiment
they proved frame dragging
uh-huh so uh let's see what frame
bragging is well uh
wikipedia explains what the gravity
probe b experiment was all about says
the gyroscopes were intended to what
reveal how space and time are worked
by the presence of the earth so the
earth warps time and that's what these
gyrospokes were intended to prove okay
and by how much the earth rotation drags
what space time around with it so the
earth is going to drag time this is what
the gravity probe b
uh experiment was all about
and you say bill you're taking things
out of context you're uh you're taking
things too literally or you know they
have all these answers to this right and
so we go to another place says in
general relativity a masses rotation
influences the motion of objects in its
neighborhood put simply the rotating
mass drags along space-time in the
vicinity
so am i putting words in their mouth and
am i taking things out of context when
they're telling you this in your face
and you say well who knows who knows who
wrote this stuff you know maybe some guy
that doesn't know squat right okay so
let's go with nasa
here's nasa okay this comes out of their
site hopefully that's a official site
that you believe in
and it's got to do with this legios uh 2
experiment in 1992 that also started
with this frame dragging nonsense uh the
costs unknown i wasn't able to find out
what the costs were but think of it
something similar to the gravity probe b
okay so direct evidence that the earth
drags space and time around itself as it
rotates
now am i putting words in their mouth or
what this comes out of that link that
you see at the bottom there by the way
okay
the research is the most accurate direct
measurement of to date of the lens
theory effect what is that a bizarre
effect of general relativity which
predicts they do predictions in in
science right in in this uh so-called
mathematics mathematical physics which
predicts a rotating mass will drag space
around it
the lens steering effect is known as
frame dragging as the earth rotates it
pulls space time in its vicinity around
itself
now am i putting words in their mouth or
what is this
i'm telling you that these people are
saying right these people are telling
you let me get this out of here these
people are telling you that
um
there's this
thingy
they call uh frame dragging
and what is it this phenomena what it
does is uh it pulls especially time
around itself
it warps time it pulls it it drags it
they figure this out through experiments
through measurement
you paid millions of dollars
for it
so don't tell me that
you know that observation and experiment
and measurement
lead to rational conclusions
these people are all come up have come
up with irrational explanations
for how the universe works they're
saying the earth
is dragging time bending time warping
time around itself
you figure that i mean if you think
that's rational well i i
uh
you know
uh
drop the ball on now and say you know
forget it uh i throw the towel in i give
up
no it's uh not at all rational okay the
physical interpretations are idiocy
okay here uh says pseudoscience
description of entanglement yeah
absolutely entanglement is pseudoscience
okay especially the description
entanglement is instantaneous action
reaction regardless of distance without
being physically connected to another
object absolutely irrational yeah you're
right so if that is pseudoscience and
quantum communication is the
manipulation of photons resulting in an
instantaneous change in the
corresponding photons
yeah all that is irrational what the
quantum guys are saying is that if you
have two objects separated by gazillions
of miles in space one object influences
the other one instantaneously without
there being any mediation without any
contact physical contact whatsoever
and yeah that's called pseudoscience
okay yeah
so
in that he got it right that's called
pseudoscience
okay if i'll ask he says uh your
thoughts on the lecture and he shows me
this fellow known as david harriman is
uh talking
philosophic corruption of reality slash
physics
and he gives a clear language how he we
ended up with modern physics and where
we went wrong and somewhat why so he
wants me to comment on this okay well
what i can say is that um
you know when i went to see harriman's
talk he says that modern physics is
irrational
he says that uh it affects technology
that's why it's important whether it's
rational or not
and it reinforces uh the universe is
unintelligible in other words the notion
that he says that if we allow
the irrational physical interpretations
of mathematical physics
uh we're going to end up with the notion
that no one can understand how the
universe actually works don't even try
we're not going to figure it out and all
we can do that's all that mathematical
physics suggests
is that science is not
uh
is is is a process where you seek but
never find
okay so the deal is to seek to measure
to describe but you're never going to be
able to explain the mechanisms
because it's beyond our comprehension
beyond human comprehension partly
because father universe
thinks differently than humans he thinks
in maybe four-dimensional thought
and we poor
slobs here are stuck in three dimensions
so what can we possibly understand about
the universe so that's essentially what
he's saying but what's the problem i
have with him with this hairman it's not
what he criticizes which is correct it's
what uh he proposes in exchange and
that's where science
vibrates remember science is not about
criticizing
science is about proposing okay we all
can criticize that's great but then you
gotta offer something in exchange we
have to explain how this universe works
and what you propose in exchange is more
irrational than what you're
trying to get get out of the way then
you got a bigger problem you're just
creating a bigger monster and his
hairman goes back to math and that's
where the problem is and he goes back to
again you know these notions these
uh
misunderstandings of what a concept an
object is the object concept dichotomy
you know he doesn't understand the
difference between an object and a
concept
and that's where he dies but his
criticism is is great you know yeah
that's the only thing positive but see a
lot of people criticize uh
the establishment you know it doesn't
mean that they can propose something in
exchange scientist is a guy who proposes
not a guy who criticizes okay it's the
difference between the boxer who's in
the ring
and the reporter who was you know taking
notes
uh as a
as a visitor as a uh
as a
you know part of the audience
uh that guy's not in the ring fighting
so he can write whatever he wants oh
look at this he should have raised his
left foot fist and should have ducked or
whatever yeah that's easy for you to say
because you're down there why don't you
get in the ring and fight and find out
how well you do
show us how you do it
that's the scientist is the guy in the
ring not the guy not the reporter in the
audience okay so let's keep those in the
right context
okay another false a thread that makes
ropes atoms all matter has many problems
okay number one is that it is a belief
okay there's nothing of scientific
method especially experiment and observe
to give it credence okay
not a theory not at theory level where
we have repeatable experimentation with
consistent observations okay so this guy
seems to harp on
experiments belief observe
okay credence you know whether you
believe or not whether you
accept it or not in your
way of thinking right
how do these intangible physical
mechanisms not get tangled
okay so here's the answer okay
uh first of all you know it's not a
belief it's known as an assumption
and you know uh uh he'll learn that when
he gets to high school he'll learn if he
takes a course in physics okay
theasis and agnostics they're idiots all
three of them why because an idiot is a
guy with big ideas as i said before
and when you talk about credence you're
talking about religion about belief
about opinion
okay so credence plays no part
whatsoever in science and again we're
not talking about belief we're talking
about an assumption you make an
assumption you say let us assume
right that the
gravity light is mediated by a rope by
thread by whatever and then you try to
explain your theory based on that
assumption that's how the scientific
method works
okay a theory has nothing to do with
experiment
and observation if you put experiment
and observation together you don't end
up with a theory okay and here let me
prove it to you okay let's prove
uh with a little experiment here okay
here's an experiment
i do it all the time very dangerous very
expensive okay we let go of the pencil
and it falls to the desk falls downward
to make it repeatable to me scientific
we do it twice at least okay so we you
see that every time i let go of it it
falls downwards no strings attached okay
there's just nothing here nothing there
let go of it falls downwards okay okay
so we have experiment and we have
observation
did we do science
is it was that science
you want to do it at home now
to verify the experiment do your own
observation go ahead just let go of the
pencil
and then
tell me if you did science if that's
scientific what you did
so no science is not observation and
experiment measurement prediction none
of that has anything to do with science
sciences explain the mechanism why what
caused the pencil to fall to the floor
okay so um
this guy harps on intangibility and
intangible means untouchable
untangleable okay
so um
to say so if he says okay these are
intangible ropes okay
or threads
then he says how come they can't touch
how come they don't get tangled well you
can't get tangled if it's intangible by
definition
i don't so
all i can recommend is the problem is
that you lack basic understanding of the
english language you should take
english as a second language 101 as a
prerequisite to science 101
so yeah before you
go into science 101 you know or physics
101 whichever one you you're going to
take in high school
uh you should first take english as a
second language because you don't know
right now you don't understand
the difference between you know if
something is intangible it means
it's untouchable
untouchable means it can't get tangled
or anything like that because it can't
touch something else you can't even make
contact
because it's untouchable intangible
right and this guy says if it's
intangible why does it why can't it
touch something how how come it doesn't
get tangled
because it's intangible that's is
you just need to learn the word
intangible okay look it up
or when you get to high school maybe
they'll teach you what intangibility
means okay fellow says the magic rope is
the electromagnetic rope that ties every
atom together but never tangles another
tango
all these guys love to tango or gets
caught on anything the phantom thread is
the object that doesn't exist that bill
gates uses as a backdrop to present
physics on
they are apparently irrational but my
problem with them is that they aren't
very useful
okay
percy attacks it says they're magical he
says the rational okay i don't know if
they're magical i think there's a
difference between rational and magical
right
there is no good reason
not to substitute these geometric models
geometric model what the hell is that
with geometric arithmetic models we can
do math with if they are analogous
okay let's answer this poor fellow and
magic only when compared to macro
objects again these people are harping
on touch
okay so they say in the macro world in
our everyday world we touch things and
so how come i can't touch this uh thing
that mother nature has out there with
which she mediates
you know gravity uh magnetism
electricity the workings of the atom etc
we have all this stuff it's intangible
and here let me show you once again
let's see if i don't know i'll try to
prove it to you okay here's evidence
i hope you believe okay here i'm going
to let go of the pencil here's nothing
here i can't touch i can't see
anything there other than there you know
i can't see the air but i can touch the
ear but i can't see or touch whatever is
pulling this thing downwards okay
always falls to the ground i don't know
why never falls to the ceiling
and so it is intangible it is invisible
and this person says why can't i touch
it
well because it's intangible and
invisible that's why you can't touch or
see
what are you gonna answer these guys you
know they don't understand the word
intangible they don't understand the
word invisible yeah mother nature's
mediators are
invisible and intangible hopefully
whatever you use to
explain your theory with
had better be intangible and invisible
because if it is tangible and visible
you have not explained mother nature's
universe
or father
universe's world you know you have not
explained that world out there because
that world is mediated by intangible
invisible objects
if you come in there and you say oh how
come i can't touch it well hopefully we
can't touch it because if you go to the
lab you can touch
whatever mediates gravity or whatever
mediates light whatever mediates
magnetism
then it's not mother nature's universe
because her world is mediated by
intangible invisible objects
okay and if you don't put an object
there
you're introducing spirits you're
introducing black magic into your
explanation
okay i hope that sinks in maybe maybe
i'm lucky
okay um
and i don't know uh science useful what
is this useful stuff see he said let me
push this over here this is something
about useful he said uh
um it's not very useful well useful has
to do with technology we don't care
about useful in science science is all
explanation we need to explain the
mechanisms of how this universe works we
don't care if it's useful especially for
you or to build a car or a house
usefulness has nothing to do with
science it only has to do with
technology
and then rope is not our geometric model
whatever that is i have no idea what
this person is talking about
uh and no uh
it doesn't equal a arithmetic or
mathematical model because math is
description and physics is explanation
so please do not confuse physics with
math
okay so i don't again know what these
people are thinking about uh i think
they are mathematical
okay
what is an idiot a person with big very
big ideas okay
he doesn't have little ideas he has
ideas
it's not as idiots okay
uh falsehoods also all this stuff about
objects it just kills their religion so
they're fighting with everything they've
got okay
an object is 3d
in a 3d spatial environment which we can
see and touch with human senses or
detect measure using technology
so again
very simple is the table on the other
side of the universe that you can't see
or touch or ever hope to an object
is the table
that the klingon has
in his planet where we can't see or
touch from here so far away gazillions
of
uh light years right away
we can't see or touch it so is that a
table an object
does the word table belong to the group
or set known as objects
is a table an object anywhere
the table in the klingons world a table
on the other side of this planet uh the
table that i have in my house which you
can't see or touched right now you know
you can't see or touch it is that is the
word table
an object
doesn't belong to the set of objects
and that's the only issue
shape on the other hand uh you can have
shape you don't have to see or touch it
if a table has shape you can draw it you
can visualize it you can make an image
you can imagine it the word imagine
comes from image right if you can
make a picture of it in your mind or on
a piece of paper it's an object
very simple if you can't it's a concept
it's either constant or object black or
white yes or no on or off that's
straightforward
shape literally has nothing to do with
defining objects well that's just an
unsubstantiated statement
you haven't justified that you just made
a statement uh baseless statement okay
no justification for your opinion belief
and again the definition of the word
object destroys all religions all these
people fight they scratched
you're killing me you're killing me bill
yeah i know i'm so sorry that your legit
religion has to die okay so here it is
he continued says the problem defining
object that which has shaped is that
there are many shapes that aren't
objects 2d 40 5d
shadows holes
and again these poor people you know
they struggle with all this and so the
first thing is name a single 2d shape
that isn't an object in other words that
doesn't have shape
he's saying that has a okay
so so if it has shape it's an object by
definition and you're saying there's a
2d shape that isn't an object you're
just violating the definition that's all
you're doing so you're going you're
you're contradicting yourself okay you
either go with the definition of shape
or you come up with something else you
got to tell me
if a 2d shape is not an object y is an
object according to the definition and
the only way you can do that is coming
up with another definition okay
that you can defend
and hopefully it's not c or touch
because you can see or touch any shape
or
you can at least see it whether you can
touch it that's a separate issue
there are no 4d or 5d shapes
but i would love for you to draw one
okay any 4d or 5d shape i want to see it
okay so please prove
that there are 4d and 5d shapes other
than in
lululand okay or after 10 beers anyways
shadows and holes are not standalone
independent therefore they do not have
shape
shape is all around and
no shadow is all around okay
because
the shadow continues all the way to the
light source okay so
uh light is simply a um
what do you call it a spirit essentially
what is light light is just a bunch of
uh ropes connected to something and you
see the vibrations
essentially of those rope the torsions
and that's what um this uh
shadow is and a whole well once we
remove everything that's around it well
we have no hole
so
you're confusing uh
the
glass the empty glass with the
filled part of the glass uh we're saying
that uh you know bugs bunny's hole
is not an object you say well it has
shape no one has shape is
the ground that's what has shape okay if
we remove the ground
there is no hole
okay so hold is not an object sorry okay
yeah it takes a long time for these
people to understand holes and objects
and and shadows are not objects hologram
is not an object okay
hologram is a shadow 3d shadow
just a bunch of lights that's all they
are game of lights
that's what a shadow is
okay and whole you uh again you can't
put a hole in space
you take the hole in space just a hole
don't bring the uh the the ground you
know bugs bunny has this hole in the
ground don't bring the ground just bring
the hole okay let's put it in space
or bring your shadow in space just a
shadow okay and see if it stands alone
okay is there such a thing as a
standalone shadow is there such a thing
as a standalone hole or do you need
something is it a dependent object
meaning
actually a concept right a dependent
concept
but is it a
is it a stand-alone object okay and we
don't have to specify that in the
definition because you have a bunch of
idiots that say oh but you should put
that in the definition then no we do not
have to we say that it has to have shape
okay and that already means it's
standalone okay you don't need to have a
dependent object in order for it to have
shape you cannot say like for example
the
halo of an angel
you know if you just put the halo
whether it's a plate or a ring that's an
object
but if you call it halo now it has to
have the angel now it's a dependent
object because
the halo is a holy ring or a holy plate
okay so
in order for it to be holy you need that
angel or that holy man underneath it
okay without that all you have is a ring
or a plate you don't call it a halo
okay halo becomes halo only with
uh something in there so the word halo
is not an object
halo is a concept because it's not a
dependent and independent object the
independent object is known as a ring or
a plate
and again it takes a long time for these
people to learn all these arguments okay
and that's why they fight because they
want to see if they can destroy the word
object as that which has shape
and they can't and so they bring issues
of
tradition democracy authority they say
well this is what they taught me oh i'm
so sorry you went to the wrong you
should ask for your money back he went
to the wrong school monastery
okay phil says many objects have no
defining shape and require containment
to have one yeah irrelevant
because we're not talking about
what is the shape of air what is the
shape of
uh water
we're saying does it have shape
does energy have shape
does mass have shape
does force does time have shape
it's not a question of what is
the shape of energy what is the shape of
time so it's not a what is it's a does
it okay
that's that's what you got to figure out
and uh
it's a yes or no type of question and so
the question is if you have uh again you
don't need to put a
container okay you can take air in a
balloon pop the balloon in space an
astronaut does that for us and you
color-coded the blob or you can use
water for that matter if you want to use
water use water that way you can show
very clearly that this water suddenly
comes out and it's in your regular blob
and the guy said what is the shape of
that blob
well it's a blobby shape
it's a blobby shape okay it has shape
it's a yes or no question that thing has
shape now what is the shape of that blob
well it's blobby i don't
what are you gonna tell these people
okay
my god my devil
my poor devil
he's rolling around in his grave down
there okay final issue conceptually
thoughts or ideas
uh yeah you didn't define all you said
is thought an idea you look of thought
it's an idea what is idea any conception
a thought
so all you did is give me a synonym okay
and we define it as a word that invokes
your embodies two objects now you don't
have a synonym you have a definition
if you don't like it
come up with an alternative give us a
definition
of the word concept
that does not include
synonyms
and with that i'll see you